vingt et un ans c'est le temps que rené
doyon a dû patienter pour que son rêve
se réalise
pour la première fois depuis ces bâtards
la loge de sang et c'est que c'est comme
si c'était ce projet là était une
abstraction mais là je rêve me réveille
tous les matins et ok là c'est un jour
de moins non je sens vraiment la
fébrilité on là je me sens vraiment que
ça s'est remis et qui plus est le
télescope est déjà rendu là bas et tout
se passe bien la balle et d'orly la
phase finale
l'astrophysicien et responsable
scientifique de la participation
canadienne au télescope spatial james
webb un projet qui l'a accompagné en ans
l'essentiel de sa carrière
j'aime jouer
effectivement beaucoup d'émotion et moi
ça fait 20 ans que je travaille sur ce
projet là tout le canada y travaillent
donc le canada était là aussi c'était
absolument incroyable quand la fusée
ariane s'est envolé le matin de noël
c'est un peu son bébé qui quittaient en
fait le nid
des jumeaux en fait deux appareils
installés à bord du télescope
space telescope
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'oiseau a déployé ses ailes avec pour
mission de nous éclairer sur l'enfance
de l'univers et les mondes extra
solaires entre autres
james webb c'est le plus grand télescope
jamais envoyé dans l'espace
comparé à son prédécesseur robot son
miroir est six fois plus grand il peut
donc percevoir des lueurs encore plus
infimes et lointaines
[Musique]
l'autre grande distinction c'est que
robot a surtout été pensé pour observer
la lumière visible celle qu'on peut voir
à l'oeil nu james webb lui voit
l'univers différemment un peu comme une
caméra thermique il est conçu pour
détecter les ondes infrarouges
une faculté censé lui permettre de
percevoir les premières lueurs de
l'univers
c'est sa mission scientifique on veut
d'abord trouver les premières galaxies
qui se sont allumées on pense une
centaine de millions d'années après le
big bang les galaxies les plus
lointaines à plus de 13 milliards
d'années lumière de nous et met beaucoup
de lumière dans les longueurs d'onde
ultraviolette mais dans l'univers en
expansion
ces ondes s'étire et leur rayonnement
lointaines ou pas revient sous forme
d'onde plus longue dans l'infrarouge
donc il arrive un moment où ce que
balles visibles c'était la lumière
principal que carbo pouvesle détectée on
ne voit rien donc il faut vraiment aller
dans les freins rouges pour pouvoir
détecter ces premières galaxies là
james webb abrite quatre instruments
scientifiques le fruit d'une
collaboration entre la nasa et les
agences spatiales européennes et
canadiennes
je pense qu'on peut le qualifier de
l'une des machines est plus complexe que
l'humanité construite là
l'équipe dirigée par rené doyon a fourni
un de ces instruments d'observation en
plus d'un appareil de guidage est
essentielle au bon fonctionnement du
télescope
pour le canada c'est le plus grand
projet spatial scientifique de son
histoire
[Musique]
l'image qu'on voit ici c'est l'image de
gemini ou est-ce qu'on voit les
aventures de rené doyon avec james webb
commence au début des années 2000 depuis
l'obtention de son doctorat dix ans plus
tôt il est chercheur à l'université de
montréal spécialisée dans l'astronomie
infrarouge faut dire qu'à l'époque la
son ami evra où j'étais à ses premiers
balbutiements et il est vraiment né ici
au québec à l'observatoire du mont
mégantic et quand ou début des années
2000 les américains ont voulu partir ce
projet là et qui hélas le canada se
positionner comme partenaire belle nos
collègues américains se sont tournés
naturellement vers le québec une
collègue de l'université de l'arizona
lui propose alors de participer à
développer les instruments d'observation
que les américains comptent installé sur
le télescope
cette collaboration s'ajoute à ce qui
est à l'époque la seule contribution
canadienne prévue au projet web un
appareil de guidage ou fgs pour fine
guidance center
le rôle du fpsc de maintenir le
télescope bien fixés sur ces cibles
pendant les observations
faut comprendre que lorsqu'on pointe une
étoile galaxie est encore délibération
matthias kopp ou d'une dérive qui fait
que si on corrigeait pas ces dérives la
lise macherey embrouillé et sas
absolument cruciales il faut vraiment à
corriger ça la lumière venus des confins
de l'univers et réfléchi sur l'immense
miroir de web de 6 mètres et demi de
diamètre
dans ce champ visuel la caméra du mgs
fixe une étoile et mesure sa position
seize fois par seconde dès qu'elle bouge
il modifie l'angle d'un petit miroir à
l'intérieur du télescope pour ajuster
l'image des étoiles observées
ce cas mary lloyd est extrêmement
précise on parle de deux détecte un
mouvement d'un millionième de ça vous
dit rien mais il y en a 2 degrés là
c'est l'épaisseur d'un cheveu vue à un
kilomètre tout je dis bien toutes les
observations toutes les découvertes que
web va produire aurait été permis par la
caméra de guidage
au début des années 2000 la conception
du mgs par les canadiens est acquise
mais leur participation à la portion
observations du télescope
badley
la nasa revoit ses priorités et renonce
à une contribution canadienne dans
l'instrument américain grosse déception
pour rené doyon et son équipe mais ils
ne sont pas prêts à se résigner
il propose de concevoir leurs propres
instruments et de l'ado cfds on l'a
proposé à l'agent spécial el al azhar
qui ont dit oui pourquoi pas mais votre
priorité c'est la caméra gilad donc
arnaud tant que vous gardez vous votre
travail priorise la camarade village
vous pouvez faire votre instrument ce
problème là est devenue une opportunité
pour nous donc on avait notre profession
pendant les années qui suivent la
carrière de rené doyon prend de
l'expansion en 2007 il devient directeur
de l'observatoire du mont mégantic un
endroit qui lui est cher
si que tout a commencé un jeu je suis né
à 1h10 y ait un terrain mais j'ai dit
souvent que professionnellement je suis
né dans ce don
web ce télescope infrarouge et
l'astronomie infrarouge ont vraiment
débuté ici autour du mont mégantic dont
la fin des années 80 lorsque j'ai fait
ma maîtrise ici donc oui j'ai été formé
ici comme un sonomètre auront à leur
tour du morbihan
[Musique]
on
encore aujourd'hui l'observatoire sert
de banc d'essai pour des instruments
d'imagerie infrarouge
il participe aussi activement à la
recherche d'exoplanètes
c'est d'ailleurs ici que rené doyon et
ses collègues ont fait leurs premières
armes dans la recherche de ces mondes
extra solaires
son sujet de prédilection
moi je dis j'ai été formé dans mon
doctorat pour utiliser galaxies en
interaction
donc si mes premières amours mercadal
1,15 arrive la toute première découverte
d'une planète extrasolaire et ça c'était
vraiment une révélation c'était un rêve
que commencer de pouvoir peut-être
prendre des images de ce planète lors
ses premiers clichés d'un système de
planètes extrasolaires en orbite autour
de leur étoile il les obtient en 2008
pour ses photos il sera d'ailleurs nommé
avec ses collègues david lafrenière et
christian marois scientifique de l'année
de radio canada
l'époque est faste dans le domaine des
exoplanètes
avec james webb rené doyon veut aller
encore plus loin
malheureusement à la même période après
près de sept ans de travail son équipe
doit se rendre à l'évidence son
instrument est trop fragile
lorsqu'on fait des tests de vibration
une caste de choc pour simuler le
lancement
ayant envoyé des petits problèmes et
donc c'était un élément fragiles et donc
avec le temps l' agence m'a demandé de
considérer une solution de rechange
forcé de revoir leur concept les
chercheurs en profite pour adapter la
pareille au domaine florissant des
exoplanètes mais il faut faire vite
quand je lui présentais à mes collègues
tout le monde était excité a emballé
parce qu'on avait des mois d'observation
qui étaient complémentaires et même
assez unique le problème c'est que bon
alors c'est le 9 juin 2011 qu'on annonce
le qu'on peut faire le changement l'asie
très bien mais vous devez livres et
autres instruments le 31 juillet 2012
l'équipe va donc travailler
d'arrache-pied pour accoucher en un an
de cet instrument ni rice pour nine fred
et me john hensley ce spectrographe
c'est un spectrographe qui décompose la
lumière infrarouge en spectre pour
analyser ces différentes longueurs
d'onde
sa double roue contient des filtres et
des prismes qui modifie la lumière selon
le type d'observations que veulent faire
les chercheurs
parmi les premières cibles de rené doyon
la recherche de conditions propices à la
vie
depuis un quart de siècle on reconnaît
maintenant plus calmes et l'exoplanète
dès maintenant on connaît des planètes
dans la table sont évitables cette zone
ni trop proches nitot loin de l'étoile
où on peut espérer trouver de l'eau à la
surface de ces palettes leur essabah ce
sont les cibles qui prioritaire leur
poids dans le contexte la recherche de
la vie ailleurs
quand une planète passe devant son
étoile la lumière de cette étoile faibli
cette baisse de luminosité permet de
détecter des exoplanètes par la méthode
dite du transit
grâce à la puissance de james webb la
lumière émise pendant le transit
permettra de découvrir de quoi est faite
l'atmosphère de ces planètes
si la paix est une atmosphère le petit
anneau autour et l'amateur filda lumière
de l'étoile derrière donc forcément
c'est qu'on fait aux principes et de
l'étoile avant le transit et pendant il
ya en comparant les deux en fait on
inspecte net qui celui de mots soir si
une mesure extrêmement délicat difficile
à faire qui ont fait beaucoup mieux dans
l'espace et surtout avec un grand
télescope donc les web était vraiment
optimisé pour faire ça et en particulier
notre instrument qu'est l'amour
dans ces atmosphères ultra lointaine les
scientifiques vont chercher la signature
lumineuse de l'eau du carbone ou du
métal des indices que la vie il serait
possible
webb ne va peut-être pas découvrir de la
vie mais va sûrement lui faire franchir
des points importants en faire cette
grande découverte la historique n'est
pas importante qui ont commencé par une
chorégraphie complexe celle du
déploiement du télescope
à cause de sa taille il a dû être replié
sur lui-même pour entrer dans la tête de
la fusée ariane 5
[Musique]
en route vers son orbite à un million et
demi de kilomètres de la terre il a
fallu le déplier des centaines d'états
qui aurait pu faire dérailler la mission
la portion la plus délicate l'écran
solaire cinq mains ce feuillet de la
taille d'un terrain de tennis qui devait
se déployer dans une séquence parfaite
c'est la partie la plus effrayante en
fait parce que ça paraît pas mais en
fait vous pu le deviner la mais se
mécanise là c'est pas moins de 300
points de défaillance potentielle sans
retour ça aussi insolent de 6-2 6-2
mécanisme ne fonctionne pas c'est pas
mal terminée point sur son orbite james
webb suivra la terre autour du soleil et
leur fera d'eau en permanence
car l'appareil doit être refroidie au
maximum à moins 230 degrés celsius c'est
primordial pour éviter que la chaleur
émise par le soleil ou la terre
n'interfère avec la lumière infrarouge
qu'il veut mesurer
jusqu'à une température y mettre de la
lumière mais la lumière dans l'effroi
rouge et s'offre une lumière parasite
qu'on veut qu'on veut éviter est la
seule façon de l'éviter c'est de
refroidir tout ce qui est tout ce qui
est autour dans le death cab inclus
c'est pour ça qu'on met web à la bride à
ses jalons d'un écran solaire pour
qu'ils se refroidisse
[Musique]
il faudra encore quelques mois pour
ajuster le télescope est lancée les
observations
ensuite il pourra enfin commencer à
répondre à la question qui obsède rené
doyon y at il de la vie ailleurs dans
l'univers
mais je peux pas imaginer que parmi une
centaine de milliards d'étoilés de
galaxies parmi les centaines de
milliards de galaxies de only sauce peut
pas accepter
une certitude qui en cache une autre
celle que dans cette immensité la
réponse est peut-être tout proche ce qui
est intéressant c'est que ça fait des
millénaires qu'on pose la question et
nous là on est la génération à ce qu'ils
voient pas le revoir ça et c'est ça qui
est chouette
[Musique]